well joining me now to discuss the
conflict in Israel and Gaz it's a TV
host in Satur is Bassam youf Bassam it's
great to have you back on the program I
wish it was under different
circumstances um first of all what is
your reaction to What happened on
October the
7th oh it was terrible of course I mean
we kind of get our news kind of also
secondhand because you know my my wife's
family they live in Gaza they they have
uh cousins and uncles there um and uh
their house also was bombed we haven't
been able to communicate with them for
the past three days communication are
lost so we don't know actually what is
the uh how is like how are they're doing
but you know we used to that I mean it's
it just like it's it's it's very
repetitive we used to that we used to
them being bombed every time and moving
from one place to the other uh you know
it's just like those Palestinians
they're very dramatic ah Israel killing
us but they never die I mean they always
come back you know they they're very
difficult to kill very difficult people
to kill I know because I'm married to
one I tried many times couldn't kill her
I mean there's a dark humor there and I
understand why because no it's not dark
humor I really I try to get to her every
time but she uses our kids as human
Shields I can never take her
out again I understand the the humor but
I to be serious basam about this tonight
there is okay I will be serious no I I I
I will be serious I was watching your
interview with Ben Shapiro and I'll will
tell you one thing I think that Ben
Shapiro is one of the smartest people
who ever walked this Earth he's very
very smart I follow him and I believe
everything he said and when he came out
on your show his solution was and I
quote his solution was that the solution
for this is for Israel to Annex Gaza and
to kill as many son of [__] as
possible to make sure that this will
never happen again and anyone anyone who
call for a ceasefire will be a terrorist
Sy Aizer so God forbid I don't want to
be labeled as a terrorist sympathizer so
I agree with Ben shapir I think we
should kill as many son of [__] as
possible let
me so far 3,500 people were killed
including 5,000 son of [__] in the
bombing of the Baptist uh uh uh hospital
as we speak right now onethird of those
3,500 were children so my question to
Ben Shapiro is how many more son of
[__] do we need to kill so Beno is
happy because it changes from changes
from I'm I'm I'm sorry that list I'm I'm
I'm I'm really at a disadvantage here
I'm looking at a camera I don't see you
I can hear you on my the reason I'm
interrupting is I think you might be I
think I think you're conflating
different interviews with Ben Shapiro he
didn't use the phrase sons of [__]
with me let me play to you what he
actually said on my did he did he did go
back go back to your interview he didn't
that was another interview but let me
play what he said to me
here well I frankly I I don't believe in
proportionate response to terrorism I
believe that the way that you stop
terrorism is with wildly
disproportionate response that doesn't
mean in terms of targeting civilians it
means in terms of killing as many
terrorists as humanly possible and
allowing them to dictate the terms of
Engagement by hiding behind civilians in
areas that that they are supposedly
responsible for means that the only
option for Israel is to surrender to
hamas's hatred of its own citizens its
willingness to use its own children as
human Shields no no country worth it
salt could ever do that now that is sign
substantively different to what you said
he said right he's talking there
specifically about I agree I I I agree
with him the the thing is the question
is what is a proportionate response
because it has been different from one
tier to other so if you look to this
graph for example this is the death of
Israeli and Palestinians and it's
changing from one year to year it's like
fluctuating like crypto so my question
is today what is the going rate today
for human lives I mean 2014 was a great
year for Ben Shapiro 88 Israelis were
died and there was 2,000 329
Palestinians killed on the other side
that is one Israeli for 27 Palestinian
that is a very good exchange rate what
I'm saying is what is the exchange rate
for today so you guys will be happy
that's my question well it's not me it's
not me guys I I I'm not on either side
no no not you like when I say you guys I
say like the people on the other side of
that I know that you you don't think
like that appear you one of the good
guys but let me tell you something I
mean I'm the reason that I'm I'm using
this is that I mean I I can't remember
what happened in 2014 and there was no
music festival but there there must be
something I mean they must do something
it is their fault it has to be something
I mean 2018 300 Palestinian died ah
who's counting you know so the thing is
what my question is let's find what is
the exchange rate for human life today
so we know expect the future death of
Palestinians and will be happy to it my
my response to that would be this B I
thought carefully about this because I
think I think it's very tricky for
people like me to immerse ourselves into
a conflict where we're not directly
involved and I thought carefully about
what I feel about this I feel that the
scale of what Hamas did on October the
7th supersedes anything else I've seen
in this conflict really ever that the
the savagery The Butchery the slaughter
of 1300 people the shooting of babies
the kidnapping a grandmother and so on
so if if we can agree on that which I
think is inarguable then the question
then becomes again about proportion I I
don't disagree that there's been a lot
of bad stuff on both sides going back
historically for decades but if we agree
that this was on a different level altoe
quite deliberately by Hamas designed
designed to provoke designed to here's
my question let me ask you a question
and and the question you you raised it
earlier about proportion I honestly
don't know what the proportionate
response is uh I I honestly don't I I
don't I've been watching the air strik
we question well I was ask I well I
would ask you if you were
Israel what would you was Israel if you
were Israel and that had happened to you
what would you think would be the
appropriate way for the country to
respond I would do exactly like Israel
did Kill as many people as possible
since the the the word is letting me do
it I mean I I can do it because I can
you know but the thing is you know what
I agree with you and you know what I'm
going to be even ahead of you because I
see the question coming do you condemn
hamz for the atro yes I condemn Hamas I
condemn Hamas I condemn Hamas is the
source of all evil there for and you
know what let's for a minute imagine a
world without Hamas right what will this
word look like let's give this word a
name and let's name this word the West
Bank Hamas has absolutely no control in
the West Bank and since the beginning of
this only through August 37 Palestinian
kids were killed no music festival no
paragliding no Hamas since the
occupation of the the West Bank 7,000
Palestinians were killed no music
festival no paragliding no Hamas I can
go on and on and on and on no no but you
don't you don't need to because in a way
in a way you're preaching to the choir
i' I follow this crisis Oh no you're not
preaching so the thing is like I in
sense I know I know that what you're
saying has validity of course of course
Pier Pierce by the way Pierce Pierce
Pierce I am at a disadvantage here I can
hear you I cannot see you I am in a
don't interrupt me and interrupt my
points sure so because this this this
has to be fair because if you want to
only hear your opinion I can just
condemn ham and go home I can do that so
if do you want to do that or do you have
a much more Nuance conversation no I
absolutely want to have a Nuance
conversation I wasn't aware I was
interrupting you I thought I was let
amazing so let's I mean I mean I would
say I would say I really applaud Israel
for doing one thing that no military
force in the word does because I heard I
heard Ben Shapiro and I heard Ronda
santis and they said said they said
Israel is the only military force in the
world that warns civilians before
bombing them I mean how [__] cute
that is so nice of them because with
this logic if Russian troops started
warning ukrainians before bombing their
houses we're cool with Putin right I
mean okay Habibi you have warned them go
invade it's fine you have done your job
I mean the thing is and I understand and
I also heard Ben Shapiro talking about
uh about human she so you remember my
wife's family they live in Gaza so I
asked them I told them when Israel give
you the nice warning the cute warning
does Hamas force you to stay in your
home so you can be bombed and use a as
as human shield you know what Hassen
here my my wife's uh my wife's cousin
he's a he's he's a loser you know he he
told me you know when I asked him does
that happen he told me no the lying son
of a [__] lied to me I told him you
don't understand Ben Shapiro and R the
santis keep saying that Israel warns you
and Hamas ask you to keep to stay put so
I I I told you he's a loser he never
kept a job he even like failed in all of
the interviews to become like a human
shield I I I would believe Ben shapir so
let's go with that no no no let's no no
let me ask at some point I must be able
to ask you questions it's not we age if
we agree if we agree the the 14,000
casualties I mean who's counting are
human shield does that mean that every
single one of those civilians was
standing obscuring a military Target
behind them because that's a lot of
weapons I mean Hamas is packing no of
course it doesn't and look I you know so
so so there is some collateral damage
lots of collateral damage yes it's fine
yeah you kill you kill some to save some
and then kill some more yeah I agree
yeah yeah yeah I agre I would let me ask
you this again it comes back to
proportionate response when the world
when the world decided it had to get rid
of Isis because of the appalling
Butchery they were carrying out uh it
did so by by also killing very sadly a
lot of civilians along the way by doing
air strikes against places which killing
civilans are inevitable you said that in
the beginning it's inevitable but once
Israel once Israel has decided that they
want to get rid of Hamas and Hamas is
embedded with civilian population I'm
very concerned about what's going to
happen next I've written a column
tonight saying I remember the Iraq which
I opposed right I remember all this so
my question to you is I know what would
be what would you think would be in
response by Israel to what happened well
well the these are years of
disproportionate responses of Israel did
it solve the solution did it solve the
problem did did it work before so it
will what what will be the surprise this
time what will be the twist that will
make this work this time what what will
be different this time seriously I mean
like this is only the last 15 years I
mean because it's too too many papers I
just got this but what how will this
will be different and the thing is it I
am so glad in the introduction that you
mentioned the Iraq War I applaud you
pierce for saying that because you were
honest about it you said that spreading
lies like wmds make people look at those
people as less of humans and they would
accept the death of a million Iraqi
whether by sh sanctions or by Invasion
right you are you you are a good man
this is amazing and you know what is
similar is when you spread the lies of
40 decapitated babies although it was
refuted so what happened happens when
people hear that you know killing babies
is horrible but when you say decapitated
40 babies you are planting a certain
image trigger in people's mind who has
said that who has said 4 who said that
you said 40 decapitated who has said
that you have you have repeat no no I
haven't what I've never said that you
haven't said on your show 40 decapitated
babies never Ben shapir didn't say it
Ronda Sanz didn't say it nobody has said
okay P nobody said it no oh okay okay
maybe I am wrong decapitated here the
you're wrong I've never said that the
thing what happened what yeah well no
you're you're wrong but the thing is
when Iraq the thing is the same thing is
happening in Iraq Ben Shapiro once
tweeted not even about Gaza about the
West Bank when Israel continued to build
the illegal setem he said 2017 Israel
likes to build things and Arabs not
Palestine not Hamas Arabs like the bomb
crap and live in open sewage yeah I
thought that was very very the Israeli
the Israeli defense the isra defense
minister he said those are human animals
and the thing is Ben shapir should know
better because you know long before the
Holocaust before Jewish people were
thrown in the gas
Chambers the Nazi propaganda called them
rats now as a human being I will never
accept that another human being being
thrown in a into a g chamber but a rat
kill 10 kill a th000 3,500 they are son
of aitu they are human animals who live
in open seage and decapitate babies and
because of that propaganda Mr Morgan
that guy in Illinois the 71 years old
guy he killed stabbing the six years old
Palestinian kid in Ino 26 times and he
used to play with him they used to be
friends but he went in marching into
their apartment stabbing his mother and
killing him shouting all Muslims could
die it took you 8 years to change one
word from Jewish to Muslim and then you
transferred your guilt to us and took
away our land let me ask let me ask you
a question that deal sucks man let me
ask you a question uh how do we get from
where we are now to
peace well first of all you need to
change the perception uh Nikki Haley the
American presidential candidate said we
are in Israel in this because it's a
fight between EV good and evil now if
you already decided someone is good he
can do no evil and if you decid that
someone is evil it's good to kill them
killing them is good you see the thing
is it is it is not like something new I
mean I I I look at history and I see I'm
sorry to say and I'm sorry to say this
but westerners has always dealt like
this with indigenous people you first
treated them like Savages you know
Native American First Nation Aboriginal
they're Savages kill all the Savages and
then when they're almost extinct you
start feeling sorry for them you know
like animals so maybe maybe the solution
is that we kill as many pal Ians as
possible so the few of them that remains
do not bother you and
maybe for another years become a tree
hugger let me just challeng you on this
and he will campaign for for preserving
the keep talking about westerners like
me okay so let me return the favor okay
Hamas is dedicated to the complete
eradication of Jewish people I am not
the spokesman for ham why do you why do
you spokesman [__] hate them [__]
H are you happy you're missing my point
you're talking in a generalized way
about people in the west who always talk
about Arabs as Savages I don't no no no
I'm
talking the campaign I led the media
campaign in this country against the
Iraq War okay so I don't see I don't see
people in the Middle East Savages say
the goodes but what I say talking about
you you're great no no it's not about me
being it's about it's about the way Hass
behaved on October the 7th was like
Savages like a pack of savages it was
the worst atrocity against Jewish people
the Holocaust there has to be of course
there has to be a response and my
question beic my question for you ising
the history B what is the proportionate
response but I don't know but there's no
Hamas in the West Bank and they're still
dying there so what's your excuse I
don't have any
excuse okay what's what's your
explanation sorry sorry uh my earpiece
went down I I listen I don't make any
pretense that this hasn't been a massive
problem okay between Palestine and
Israel going back to the mid-40s we all
know this right I I'm I'm I'm yeah yeah
yeah Pierce Pierce Pierce listen I'm not
saying that you're making excuse but if
you are adopting a certain point of view
you have to at least defend it I'm
telling you there is no Hamas in the
West Bank what is what is the excuse not
your excuse what is the accuse to kill
those
people well it's listen this question of
proportionality is one that no no no
answer my question I've been answering
your question you answer mine it's
actually not my job to answer your
questions it's not okay not your not
your job I I I agree with you I'm more
interested in you who has family in Gaza
I'll who's an Egyptian in the Middle
East right I'm more interested in what
you have to say okay I'm telling you I'm
telling you I think Hamas is the problem
okay now let's say Hames is removed
let's ham yeah I I I'm agreeing with
everything about you want me to go ham I
will condemn ham H Hass everybody guys
so wait I can't hear you the uh the
earpiece damn okay
oops okay yeah uh I I do need I think I
think just go back is he there you go
back you go back go back okay go thank
you guys can you hear B yeah yeah now I
can hear so here's the thing can you
hear okay so Isa let's say for example
Hamas ceased to exist okay do you hear
me yes yeah Hamas ceased to exist today
now right now in Palestine in West Bank
and and uh and Gaza 20% of Palestinians
go through Israeli prison system whether
imprisonment whether interrogation
whether torture and the rest of them
they live a life of daily loss of land
of homes of life and they are they are
suffocated by the so let me ask you
something if you are a Palestinian
living into these conditions for decades
would you would you sympathize with your
oppressor or sympathize with the people
who claim they resist them even if they
are terrorist I have made I have made no
secret that I think the conditions
Palestinians have had to exist under are
completely unacceptable I've said that
for years so the question then becomes
how do you forge peace between two
Waring parts of that region who for
decades have approached peace in my view
with Mutual sledgehammers with no actual
desire to have peace and I think it
comes down in the end to great
leadership and I I don't think there's
great I don't think well hang on let me
make my point I don't think there's
great leadership on either side where is
the Nelson Mandela figure here to come
through all this
nelsonon Mandel is that nson
Mandela NE Nelson Mandela actually have
criticized Israel for being a horrible
State all of the South African activist
have actually isra my point is how he
how he responded to a country that was
so divided is a temp is a temp is a
template for how you get to peace isn't
it I I I I haven't met Danon Mandela so
I wouldn't know but like I I I there is
a point there's a there's a very
important Point here you know I want to
understand what is the logic of Israel
carpet bombing Gaza I mean if there's a
logic if there's a good if this will
make Israel safe I want to hear the
logic so if they continue bombing what
are they hoping to achieve we know what
their we know what their stated aim is
their stated aim is to eradicate and
wipe out Hamas they believe Hamas are
living are living predominantly in
Northern Gaza they also are aware
they're living amongst civilians so it's
an incredibly difficult thing as I said
as I said in my mon you know it is very
very difficult to see how they do this
without massive collateral damage so if
I can understand this correctly
basically Israel is doing this to
pressure the Palestinian community in
Gaza to turn against Hamas is that right
I'm sure that's part of it yes that's
part of it so this is exactly what
terrorist organization do because
terrorist organizations will have no
chance beating a whole nation in battle
so they terrorize and they kill the
civilians in order to spread fear and
Terror so they can turn against their
government to change their policy or to
resign you have just compared Israel
with Isis no I haven't I don't I don't
see any comparison between it's going to
be the headlines tomorrow p is Isis only
amongst people who weren't listening the
comparison which is more apite is Isis
and Hamas they are both nistic Terror
groups intent on killing as many Jewish
people and others as they can possibly
kill and you can't you can't you can't
get people like that absolutely you know
what I'm going to do something that
nobody done on your television you know
what I'm going to do on your episode I'm
going to do I'm going to pretend that
I'm an Israeli citizen I'm going to put
my my myself in the in the place of an
Israeli settler in the kaputs and I want
to speak to my prime minister Benyamin
Netanyahu Mr bamin Netanyahu I have
voted for you because you have promised
us peace and prosperity and security on
the 7th of October those son of bites
Hamas they went into defense that is
regularly heavy heavily guarded usually
if there's like a a dove that comes
close to it it will be shot those people
went in and they went for 6 hours before
IDF forces was deployed killing our
friends our families kidnapping our
grandmothers and babies and went in I
want to ask you Mr Prime Minister after
you have fractured the Israeli community
and you have [__] our courts our
Supreme Courts what are you doing with
the money being given to you to the
United States also you are carpet
bombing Gaza with absolutely no regard
to our hostages our people I heard a
rumor in the kapo
that you're doing that as an you let
that happen to as an excuse to carpet
bomb Gaza so you push them into Sinai
and I didn't believe that I like not my
prime minister he can never do that and
then I watched an interview for Danny
Alon he was your Chief advisor he was
also the Israeli ambassador to the
United States and you know what he said
Mr Prime Minister he said that the
solution for those Palestinians is to go
into a vast land of Sinai and live into
10 cities temporarily huh temporary wink
wink until we build Gaza again and then
we invite you
back we've seen this movie before so
yeah and I and when I saw this I
couldn't explain to my fellows in the
Kuts how come our Israeli government is
trading human lives for another piece of
land so as an Israeli citizen I need to
hold my Israeli government accountable
and as an American citizen I want to
know all of these money that we are
giving to Israel we giving them $4
billion every year Joe Biden said it's
the best investment they ever America
ever done well I if I am in the in the
place of Joe Biden I would say sorry
don't speak
uh I I would I would say if I was Joe
Biden I would go down and whisper in the
ears of Netanyahu and tell them I hate
bad Investments they haunt me you know
like little finger in Game of Thrones
but the thing is the thing is this is
the problem Israel always victimizes
itself and I have never seen a victim
putting their oppressor Under Siege and
24/7 Israel wants you to believe that
they are the victim is dealing with
Israel is so difficult it's like being
in a relationship with a narcissistic
psychopath he [__] you up and then he
makes you think it's your fault you look
at Israel as Superman but they're really
homelander they are like they they are
shooting and they are annoyed with the
splashes bass I want to say two things
one if you could just slightly man your
language we are uncensored but if you
keep swearing Sor we have to apologize
to viewers you may be offended by that I
apologize I understand passion Run High
so let's not get too bogged down about
the odd swe I apologize to the viewers I
apologize to the viewers for my language
my second question is this after site of
of dead civilian after the break we have
the managing director of The Daily wire
which is Ben Shapiro's company we were
going to interview him on his own but
he's happy to come on and talk with you
directly if you are prepared to
stay well of course I I I can stay but
again I am [__] this I am in a
disadvantage and I would like to have my
space to respond okay we'll come back
after the break I I because because
here's the thing there we got to go to a
break when we come back from the break
be you and Jeremy B my my I have news
we're taking a short break B I'll be
back welcome back toon for more on the
situation in Israel I'm joined now by
the CEO and co-founder of the daily wi
Ben Shapiro's partner Jeremy boring uh
Jeremy thank you very much indeed for
joining me I'm sorry we demoted you
earlier to M MD you are the CEO and Co
co-founder uh you know Ben Shapiro
better than anyone really I did a big
interview with Ben obviously the other
night um which went around the world um
and has sparked a big reaction including
from uh Our Guest Bassam Yousef who's
still with us first of all you've been
listening to to Bassam and what he's
been saying what's your
response well first of all I make it a
point not to speak for Ben Shapiro he's
got a 20 IQ points on me and speaks for
a living professionally so he's much
better prepared to defend himself but as
his business partner as his best friend
I I do feel like I have to respond to
the things that bosam was just saying
first of all the question of how many
sons of [__] have to be killed in
order to end this conflict I suppose
that the answer is as many of them as it
takes that doesn't mean that I or Ben or
any decent person in their right mind is
happy with the killing of civilians uh I
posted at the very beginning of this
conflict that a a woman or a child blown
apart in Gaza is just as tragic as a
Jewish baby killed in one of the
settlements that doesn't mean that
Israel's actions and the actions of
Hamas are morally equivalent you know
the tragedy is the tragedy but the moral
equivalency is nonsense if you if you
entered Israel with the express purpose
of targeting and murdering civilians
with your own hands and cold blood that
is not comparable to Israel bombing
Targets in the Gaza Strip and killing
civilians as a terrible tragic
consequence war war is terrible war is
an awful thing that's why decent people
don't lightly engage in War and why
hamash should not have incited this war
you know we can talk about the history
of the Israeli conflict I'm not a
professional political commentator I'm a
I'm a CEO I'm a screenwriter uh and I'm
certainly not Ben Shapiro I'm not here
to discuss the history of the Israeli
Palestinian conflict but we all saw what
happened on October 7th and the idea
that Israel was not going to react
severely to that or that Israel should
not react severely to that is ludicrous
and
Theo should be a moderating voice that
bapiro should be what saying no Israel
should not respond in this situation
that's nonsense let me ask you though
Jeremy what I mean the question which I
think is the big question what is a
proportionate response to that outrage
on October the 7th which is the worst
attack on Jewish people since the
Holocaust what is proportionate if it's
true as reports are suggesting tonight
that there may have been a hospital hit
by an Israeli strike and up to 500
people or more have died that would seem
to me if that is verified and it's not
verified yet you know we don't know
exactly what has happened other than
there's been a hit on this hospital but
if that is verified to have been an
Israeli strike that will strike many
people as disproportionate certainly
well first of all I don't know what a
proportionate response is or why we
would want it I suppose a proportionate
response would be for 3,000 Israelis to
go through the fence gun down innocent
Palestinian women and children burn
their bodies burn them alive take
hostages rape their women no one wants a
proportionate response no no moral
person could possibly call for a
proportionate response the purpose of
war is to defeat your enemy the West has
in my lifetime forgotten the purpose of
War because the true cost of war is so
terrible the last time the West engaged
in war and won it was World War II and
they did it through incredible brutality
they did it by bringing their enemies to
heal that is not a thing to that's not a
thing to rah rah about that's not a
thing to look forward to as I said all
decent people should avoid war but I
think the sort of lie of the post World
War II the post-war consensus lie is
that somehow War uh in which you kill a
bunch of people and don't secure Victory
is morally Superior to war where you do
secure Victory I would say that the only
way to morally justify a war is to win
it otherwise your AR the very argument
that brought you into the war this enemy
must be defeated ends up being proven a
lie I mean Afghanistan I think America
had every right to go into Afghanistan
uh the Taliban was harboring Osama Bin
Laden and al- Qaeda al- Qaeda flew
planes into buildings in the United
States killed thousands of our citizens
uh brought the nation into Untold Agony
pain and horror America had every right
morally to go in and destroy the Taliban
and Destroy al- Qaeda but I would argue
the Taliban now but the Taliban now
rules in Afghan the war was not won but
that's my point actually I've done a
column about this tonight uh for the sun
here in the UK which is I I was editor
of a newspaper when the Iraq War
happened I uh opposed it very
aggressively as the editor of paper um
and sadly we were born out by events it
was a complete disaster the Iraq War in
my view it was illegally contested I
think um and the consequences were
appalling in terms of loss of life a
million people in terms of Isis being
allowed to breed and create their merry
hell around the world in terms of
complete dismantlement of of Iraq itself
as a as a functioning country uh and I
think Afghanistan again 20 years of you
know attacking an enemy which is now
running the country again seemed to me
again to be kind of pointless and I do
Wonder
whether Israel in its Blind Fury which I
completely understand has thought
through the consequences of actually
launching a full air ground and sea
offensive into Gaza as to actually what
happens at the end of that well I
suppose Israel wasn't really given the
opportunity to fully contemplate what
the consequences of that action might be
because Israel didn't instigate this war
this war was instigated by a horrible
terrorist attack on Israel and a state
is put in a position where it has to
respond now one might argue that the
very fact that Israel has yet to
actually launch their ground Invasion
means that they are actually making a
calculation about what the cost will be
what victory looks like any rational
person any decent person can engage in a
conversation about what is the
appropriate response for Israel of
course they can but this sort of moral
equivalency thing I don't think is a
sign of decency to engage in a
conversation about moral equivalency let
me bring uh bassim back in you've been
listening to this bassim what's your
response to what Jeremy's been say I'm
I'm sorry I didn't catch the gentleman's
name it's Jeremy boring he's the chief
executive of the daily wire co-founder
with Ben Shapiro of a Del wire hi Jeremy
please say hello to Ben Shapiro and
please tell him that I do think he is
the smartest person to ever walk the
earth thank you so much so as response
to Jeremy uh I I I I I agree with
everything you said I mean what is
disproportionate I mean that you he just
used the uh examples from second world
war and America showing that civilian
casualty is a I mean I I heard his voice
he was very sad and he as he was telling
us it is so inevitable to kill so many
civilians because it's something that we
cannot avoid I hear the sadness in his
voice and I know that it's a very
difficult decision to kill all of these
civilians because that's for a higher
cast and I understand but my question I
I have two questions the question is how
can you justify The Killing In The West
Bank where Hamas does not exist and if
the disproportionate response
during the all of these years have
actually worked what will be new this
time that did not happen before I just
want to that that that was my question
that was my question I'm so so so now so
now now if I ask the question can I can
I say something on my side a little B
with respect personal Bassam with
respect I gave you half the show to have
your side Jeremy's had a lot less time
uh I'm going to have to you want me to
I'm going to have to I'm going to have
to let you go because been on there with
you for 40 minutes okay bye bye but
listen bye bye I'd like to talk to you
again and thank you for joining the
program I appreciate it oh by by by the
way my my my wife's family is is all
right and they send us a house it's it's
bombed it's beautiful it's it's going to
be a good uh uh like Halloween theme so
well I'm very sorry for what your family
are going through in Gaza and I mean
very by the way I don't know I I don't
know my I don't know him by the way I
don't I haven't actually met them they
didn't even come to my wedding they
couldn't because they are stuck in Gaza
and she never saw them because you know
Gaza is not a destination
we hear their voices and it's they they
die it's fine it's fine bassim I wish
your family all the very best thank you
for joining me I appreciate it I I don't
thank
you